this is the deepest hole mankind has
ever dug it's a straight drop into the
bowels of the earth for 20 years
Russian scientists and engineers drilled
deeper and deeper hoping to uncover
whatever mysteries the hole may hold
earning it the ominous nickname of the
well to hell what would happen if for
whatever reason you fell into this hole
what would happen to your body how deep
would you fall and what would you find
at the bottom this is what if and here's
what would happen if you fell into the
deepest hole on earth so you managed to
take the plunge
you'll start plummeting at about 10
meters per second and every second after
that it gets faster if we take terminal
velocity out of the mix and assume you
weigh 80 kilograms you'd eventually
reach a speed of four hundred and ninety
meters per second so as you fall deeper
and deeper what would happen to your
body falling at such high speed you'll
start to notice things getting a little
toasty as your heart rate starts to
elevate in panic sets in you might find
it getting a little harder to breathe
why well at 150 meters down your poor
lungs would be getting crushed by the
constantly increasing air pressure you
might also encounter what cave explorers
like to call foul air deadly underground
pockets of carbon dioxide great things
can't get much worse can they yeah they
can
less than three kilometers into the trip
you're going to see your skin start to
burn up literally and as you continue to
fall
it only gets hotter and hotter this is
because you're being pulled closer to
the gravitational center of Earth and
it's molten core which is baking the
planet from the inside out a temperature
of 80 degrees can severely burn a
person's skin in less than a second at
this point in the whole you're feeling
heat of over 180 degrees on the bright
side you've probably already passed out
when you fall out of a plane you can
pass out from lack of air but wake up as
oxygen becomes more available and catch
a glimpse of the ground as you smack
into it down here you're not waking up
okay so things don't look good but let's
say you came prepared and we're an
atmospheric diving suit Delp with the
increasing pressure as you fell it's
heavy but it will help with that
breathing problem in 2016
Luke Aikins jumped from over 70 600
meters without a parachute and survived
without a scratch granted he'd landed in
a net so if he's allowed to have one you
can too okay so you've land in the net
great including your terminal velocity
you have successfully managed to
freefall 12 kilometers straight down at
a speed of 200 kilometers per hour how
long were you falling well
factoring in air resistance and terminal
velocity the whole trip took just over
three minutes and now you've got to get
back out this is not gonna be easy but
it may not be impossible in 2018 Alex
Honnold managed to scale Yosemite
National Park's 914 meter tall El
Capitan granite wall without ropes in
just four hours
granted he wasn't wearing a huge suit
like you are this big outfit wouldn't
help you climb and you would need some
climbing equipment to help you get a
better grip on the walls of the hole
but what's it like down there to answer
that let's flashback to 1971 in the Kola
Peninsula of Northwest Russia to be
exact when Russia began work on the Kola
super-deep borehole measuring in at just
over 12 kilometers deep the Kola
super-deep borehole is the deepest whole
humankind has managed to dig on earth
team Kola had managed to break the world
record for drilling depth trying to get
a leg up on the US during the Cold War
eventually though they encountered
temperatures of 180 degrees which melted
their equipment so the hole was capped
in 1992 when you're at the bottom you'd
find things are warm to say the least
not to mention your body would be
dealing with air pressure equal to 54
elephants perched on top of your head
weighing in at a whopping 378 tons talk
about a headache at least you could
admire some of the 2.7 billion year old
rocks down there but really could
something like this falling down this
hole ever happened who knows to be
honest we're still trying to figure out
the equipment requirements for digging
this deep let alone finding someone
crazy enough to take the plunge
luckily the Kola super-deep borehole
only has a diameter of 23 centimeters so
it's too narrow for you to trip into and
even with its record-breaking depth the
Kola super-deep borehole
is only a fraction of the thickness of
the Earth's crust but it does make you
think about what humans are capable of
could we maybe dig tunnels between
continents well that's a story for
another what-if